hey everyone this is Lucy and in this
video I'll be walking you through three
beginner friendly AWS Hands-On workshops
as we all know at this point AWS
certifications are a great starting
point for learning cloud fundamentals
but if your goal is to land a job in the
cloud industry watching a 20 hour video
course on udemy and taking lots of notes
is just not enough the reason is because
in an interview you won't just be asked
to memorize what an AWS service does to
really stand out you'll need a more
in-depth understanding of some real life
scenarios where 80 bits can be used to
help companies with their business and
Technical goals for example an
interviewer can ask you what are some
ways to secure a 32 web application
that's hosted on the cloud or how can a
company migrate their on-premises
service onto AWS maybe something even
more specific like what are subnets and
why do we need them you might get away
with memorizing some of the answers to
these questions but if you've had actual
hands-on experience performing some of
these tasks and working with the core
AWS Services you'll be able to answer
the questions with a lot more confidence
and in a lot more detail and the don't
get me wrong I definitely recommend AWS
certification video courses if you're
looking to get AWS certified and build
your theoretical knowledge but after
getting one or two AWS certifications
make sure you follow that up with
hands-on experience because if you have
10 certifications but don't know how to
navigate the AWS console and actually
build something then it's going to be
very hard to Showcase your skills in a
technical interview so with all that
being said let's jump straight into
Resource number one the first Hands-On
resource I'd recommend is the AWS
General immersion day workshop as a
former AWS Solutions architect immersion
days was something that my team and I
ran with AWS customers we used to bring
together a group of AWS customers into a
meeting room or video call and walk them
through a set of presentations and
Hands-On labs for the Hands-On Labs
customers will follow the same Workshop
you can see right here on the screen
these immersion days will usually go
from let's say 9am to 4 P.M and by the
end of the session customers will have a
much better understanding of the core
AWS Cloud Concepts including compute
networking security monitor entering
databases and storage for example if we
click on compute the workshop guides you
through how to launch a web server and
connect to it it also shows you how to
set up Auto scaling groups and load
balances you can see here that there's
also an advanced section for those who
are looking for more of a challenge I'll
put the workshop Link in the video
description below if you want to give it
a go yourself it's a free Workshop but
make sure you follow the instructions to
clean up the AWS Services after creating
them to avoid unnecessary charges the
second Hands-On resource is a workshop
that teaches you how to perform an
application migration with AWS you'll
start off with a traditional three-tier
e-commerce application that's hosted on
premises and by the end of the workshop
you would have migrated it all to AWS
what's pretty cool about this Workshop
is that it goes through many different
ways you can migrate an application for
example re-hosting using AWS application
migration service or performing a
re-platform using AWS elastic Beanstalk
application migrations are a common
customer situation at AWS so this
Workshop will help you understand a real
life scenario of when AWS Services can
be used to help companies move to the
cloud the workshop is estimated to take
around four to six hours to complete and
as long as you clean up the resources
that are deployed it should cost you
less than ten dollars on your AWS
account if you're finding this video
helpful by the way please remember to
give it a like And subscribe to this
channel if you'd like to see more videos
like this okay so the first two
resources I mentioned are available for
free and if you want to access more free
Hands-On workshops I'd recommend
browsing through workshops.aws the next
resource I'm about to mention is a bit
of a bonus one this is a set of Hands-On
video projects from an instructor that I
personally trust and recommend he has
some amazing beginner friendly projects
for example this AWS WordPress one that
I mentioned in a previous video These
project courses even though they're paid
resources are great for people who want
to follow Hands-On video tutorials
instead of just following written
instructions and documentation unlike
AWS certification courses where only
around 10 of it is Hands-On Labs these
project-based courses go through step by
step how to build AWS projects and and
once you complete them you can showcase
it onto your resume I reached out to
Aziz the course creator and we decided
to partner up together to provide a
discount for all the courses so if you
use the code Tech with Lucy when you
check out you'll receive 20 off at this
point you might be feeling a bit
overwhelmed and thinking how am I meant
to find the time to use all of these
resources let me introduce you to an app
called rice which is also today's video
sponsor so rice is a desktop app that
automatically tracks and categorizes the
time you spend on certain websites and
apps what rice does is once you install
it it sits in the background and tracks
all the things you're doing on your
computer it then analyzes all of it and
provides you with real-time insights to
help you understand which websites and
apps are distracting you I spent so much
of my time in front of my laptop these
days so by tracking my time I've been
able to build better work habits and try
to avoid watching Netflix for five hours
straight so if you're interested in
maximizing your productivity you can
check out rise and the first 1000 people
just sign up with the link in the
description below or by using the code
Tech with Lucy get 25 of the first three
months with rise alright so this brings
us to the end of this video if you'd
like to see more videos like this let me
know in the comments below and I'll see
you soon bye for now